most of the sandwiches quest songs and
tart that don't sell during a normal
business day usually end up in the trash
but not at this Paris bakery the company
offers its leftover goods at a discount
price through an app done quasi
impossible not telling Jamal we
regularly have a lot of perishable goods
depending on the day we can have up to
ten to twenty percent of our stock
thrown away guess what okay yep Ella so
the application of two young allows us
to avoid wasting all this food and all
this work I guess shades at NUI trio it
with Hawaii okapi to sell the products
through the app a company must offer a
15-percent discount or more the
discounts are then flashed onto the cell
phones of potential customers in real
time because when I launch the app it
finds my location with GPS and shows me
where all the deals are bodies us almost
a hundred shops in Paris have signed up
for the app so far it's been downloaded
more than 20,000 times its developers
now hope to expand the service to other
cities actually did